-Republican leaders have
announced their opposition
to a commission to investigate
the January 6th insurrection
at the Capitol
as the GOP
intensifies its efforts
to rewrite the history
of what happened.
For more on this, it's time
for A Closer Look.
♪♪
Many Republican officials
have been desperate
to create
an alternate universe
where Donald Trump
is a beloved former president
who people miss and want back,
which is insane
for many reasons.
For one, everyone's
daily quality of life is better
without having to wake up
in the morning
to 10 different news alerts
on your phone
that all say something
along the lines of,
"President Trump accuses
Eiffel Tower of spying on him,
suggests eating a golf ball
can cure coronavirus."
The other reason
it's absurd is the fact
that Trump is our most
unpopular president
in the history
of modern polling.
He never won the popular vote,
lost by 7 million votes in 2020,
never once cracked
50% job approval,
and now spends his time
barging into weddings
to rant about voter fraud.
It's the most embarrassing thing
that could possibly happen
at a wedding,
aside from your mom
making you slow dance with her
while you're 13.
[ As teenage boy ] "Mom,
you're embarrassing me."
[ As mother ]
"Honey, fix your tie."
"I don't want to wear
the stupid bow tie.
I wanted to wear
my tuxedo shirt."
"Well, your father and I
outvoted you two-to-one."
"There was voter fraud.
My friend Mike's dad
hanging out with Hugo Chavez."
"Which friend Mike?"
[ As Mike Lindell ]
"That would be me.
Now, I know it might be weird
that I'm pals with
a 13-year-old,
but in my defense,
everything about me is weird."
Last night on Fox,
for example,
Trump's son Eric told
a ludicrous story
about how random people
are supposedly coming up
to him on the street
and telling him how much
they miss his father.
-More people have come up to me
on the street in the last week
and given me hugs, saying,
"We miss him so much."
I mean, literally, sometimes,
Sean, with tears in their eyes.
"We miss the man so much."
-Well, it's allergy season.
Everybody has tears
in their eyes.
Guy came up to me yesterday with
tears running down his face,
sniffling, and said,
"Hey, your show stinks."
Also, based on that story,
when you live in New York City,
you got to watch out
for the Impractical Jokers.
I'm pretty sure "hug Eric Trump"
was Murr's punishment
last season for losing
the grocery store challenge.
"Now, tell him you miss
his dad so much."
Second, it's nice to see
Eric has inherited
his father's penchant
for inventing anonymous adults
who cry with gratitude.
I guess when you come from a
family devoid of human emotion,
it makes sense
that you would project it
onto imaginary friends.
[ As Eric ] "And Sean, this man,
still crying, said to me,
'Also, you're a good boy
and your daddy is proud of you,'
which I thought was
very nice of him to add."
Republicans have also been busy
trying to rewrite the history
of what happened
at the Capitol on January 6th.
That's why GOP leaders
like Kevin McCarthy
and Mitch McConnell
have come out against creating
an independent commission
to investigate it.
Many Republicans have
straight up lied about it,
which is hard to swallow,
because we all,
every one of us, saw it happen
in real time with our own eyes.
Most of the people doing it
were also filming it.
It was one of those collective
national moments
where we were all watching
the same thing unfold
together in shock,
like the O.J. trial
or the Apollo 13 landing,
or David Copperfield making
the Statue of Liberty disappear.
And by the way, if you've
never been to New York,
you might not know this --
he never put it back.
All we have is
a cheap cardboard cutout.
Anyway, the point is, we all saw
the Capitol riot happen,
and if by some chance
you weren't
glued to your TV that day,
there are plenty of first-person
accounts you can watch
from reporters who were there,
documenting the violence
as it was happening.
-The pro-Trump crowd
fought with the police,
trying to break
through their lines,
intoxicated by
the unlikely prospect
of reversing
America's election outcome.
This is exactly
what was feared,
but in no way
is this a surprise.
It has being fueled
by the president's rhetoric.
We followed the aggrieved
and infuriated Trump supporters
as they stormed the building.
-I swear that's CNN.
-Through broken windows
and doors they had forced open,
the cost of that rhetoric
is increasingly clear.
-I know my rights!
-As crowds tonight are still
swirling around Congress...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
...and America's long journey
as a stable democracy
appears to be in genuine doubt.
-It's always sobering to watch
a British correspondent
report on American chaos.
[ In British accent ]
"Rioters have now
breached the capitol of
this once-proud democracy,
and like an Earl Gray tea bag
on a porcelain sink,
it will leave
an indelible stain.
Now stay tuned for yet
another rerun of 'Taskmasters.'"
Somehow, the reverse
is never as harrowing.
Even when Brexit was a mess
and the government
there was in crisis,
it just wasn't
as dramatic to listen
to an American report on it.
"Yeah, Cliff, things are not
going well over here
with all this Brexit stuff.
It's a...it's a real...
It's real mess.
Is there a hurricane
I can report on?
Because this [bleep]
is complicated."
It's the same as watching one of
those BBC Nature documentaries.
The British accents
really hit home
how dramatic it is.
It would be a lot
less compelling
with an American narrator.
"And the iguana is like,
'Alright, I'm just
gonna stay still
and that snake's
not gonna see me.
Just stay still. Stay still.
Oh, no! It saw me!
I'm gonna run crazy!
I'm going to do my crazy run.
Oh, there are so many snakes.
I think maybe right now I'm
gonna just go to the rocks.
The rocks will be
a safe place for me.
Oh, no, they live there!
This is their house.
And now I'm going to, I don't
know, activate my iguana oil.
Is that a thing?
And I'm gonna slip out
and now I'm gonna jump
like I'm on a trampoline
up this mountain.
Boing, boing.
And now the snake's like,
I got you.
And then he's gonna follow me
like, I don't have hands.
And now this iguana
is finally up here
and his friend is gonna
be like, 'Where were you?'
And it's like, 'Where was I?
How about, how am I?'"
Not as good.
But it's all there on camera
for us to see,
and yet Republicans are engaged
in an intensifying effort
to rewrite
the history of that day
by claiming, preposterously,
that the entire thing
was a peaceful protest.
-Let me be clear.
There was no insurrection,
and to call it an insurrection,
in my opinion,
is a bold-faced lie.
Watching the TV footage of those
who entered the Capitol
and walked through Statuary Hall
showed people
in an orderly fashion
staying between
the stanchions and robes,
taking videos and pictures.
You know, if you didn't know
the TV footage
was a video
from January the 6th,
you would actually think it was
a normal tourist visit.
-This didn't seem like
an armed insurrection to me.
I mean, "armed."
When you hear "armed,"
don't you think of firearms?
-There's no evidence, as has
been said on January 7th,
that this was
an armed insurrection.
There have been things
worse than people
without any firearms
coming into a building.
-Okay, first of all,
describing it as
"people without firearms
coming into a building"
leaves out a lot
of crucial context.
It's like writing a book report
about "The Great Gatsby"
that says, "Man enjoys summer
in the Hamptons."
Also, it's a lie.
There were weapons,
as the Justice Department,
reporters, and video
have all documented.
But even if that statement were
true, it's not very comforting.
If a group of criminals
breaks into your house
with some baseball bat,
smashes all your belongings,
and steals all your money,
it wouldn't exactly
make you feel better
if the cops were like,
"Hey, there are
worse things in life.
Eric Trump's out there just
hugging people in the street."
Second, peaceful tour groups
don't usually have
British correspondents
following them around
as they smash barricades,
break windows,
attack police officers,
and vandalize offices.
If it really was
a normal tourist visit,
that report would have been
a lot less dramatic.
[ In British accent ] "The group
is now moving down the hallway
into the rotunda as
the tour guide provides
a substantive history
of neoclassical architecture.
Several people are looking down
at their phones,
and one man seems to be --
yes, I can confirm
he is falling asleep.
Now, stay tuned for
an all-new 'Mock the Week.'"
I also want to draw attention to
this part of
Senator Ron Johnson's argument.
-If that was a planned
armed insurrection,
man, you have really
a bunch of idiots.
-Here's an idea --
maybe both are true.
Stupid people also make plans.
Have you ever seen an empty
Dave & Buster's?
Maybe it was
a planned insurrection
and they were idiots.
I mean, one dude was
dressed like a [bleep] Viking.
If he barged into my house,
I'd still be terrified.
If somebody barged into my house
dressed like Tom Hanks,
I'd be terrified,
and everyone loves Tom Hanks.
I wouldn't be like, "Oh, I'm
sure this Hanks enthusiast
is in my house for good stuff."
This is why we need a commission
to lay out the facts
as we know them
for the historical record,
so Republicans
can't lie about it
and create an alternate reality
where it didn't happen.
If there isn't an accurate
historical account
of the insurrection
with shame and consequences
for the people involved,
it could very well happen again.
Republicans would rather
not talk about
the consequences of their
actions, so they're whining.
-Literally, sometimes, Sean,
with tears in their eyes.
-This has been A Closer Look.
♪♪
God's Love, We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated. We love you.